[Applaudissements]
merci kabylie jouera dire si tout le
monde a adoré le dernier diamant le film
avec yvan attal avec bérénice bejo merci
d'abord eu droit à un joker
je vais revenir non mais ils auront le
[Applaudissements]
jeu vous allez vous avez vous disiez
aussi tous chacun à votre tour j'ai
adoré c'est bien les mairies cette
tension sur le chevet génial à faire je
vais vous dire oui je vais venir
allaient revenir je voulais venir le
nous transmet par exemple loyer pour le
13 mai vous regardez on avait donc
quelques jours pour les ruisseaux et
vous ferez une fiche de lecture a dit à
10% 10 ou plus sont en bout voilà vous
savez tout cela vous fiche de lecture ça
va vous calmer et vous allez arrêter de
faire chier le monde
[Applaudissements]
à